over the past few months we've had many
depressing
charts and i'm afraid that i've got some
more depressing ones but these are
really important because we're trying to
get a sense now
of the historical perspective of where
we are with covert 19 a lot of people
saying
you know how does this really compare
with other epidemics that we've had
so far this century you know was it
worse than the ones that we've had
uh in the past 50 years well now we
finally have
the data that might well be able to
prove whether the answer is yes or no
definitively
and i'm going to show you that data it's
just simply numbers
of people who have died in england and
wales for this year compared with the
previous years and what we're able to do
is look back
all the way towards the 1840s there's
lots of data on this
as you'd imagine and what that means we
can do is we can compare where we are at
the moment with
previous episodes where you had high
mortality so for instance
the potato blight of the 1840s plato
family of course
in ireland but it affected much of
europe uh as well including parts
of england as well the great freeze of
1895 very cold winter there caused very
high levels of death
uh to you've got world war one and world
war ii obviously high levels of
mortality we're talking about civilian
mortality i should say here rather than
military deaths but nonetheless you've
got higher levels of mortality in those
areas uh in those periods as well
and then you've got the post-war
epidemics so
influenza epidemic in 1951 very high
levels of deaths there
hong kong flu of 1968 1969
you might remember when we were looking
at excess deaths this this kind of
measure of total deaths across the
population
back in the the height of summer when we
were starting to get those horrible
numbers through
we were kind of wondering whether it was
as bad as hong kong flew or indeed worse
and actually some weeks of hong kong flu
had slightly higher levels of mortality
so now we finally have the annual
numbers through
we're able to make a comparison as to
whether this is more severe or less
severe than that
and here's what the numbers show so here
is covered 19 i'm going to add the line
on to show you
uh the increase in 2020 and what i'm
actually going to do is just kind of
change the axis scale so the same data
precisely the same data
but we're going to kind of zoom in so
we'll just get rid of the bottom 350
000 so you can see it more in
perspective and what you see there is
look at that line
and we're going to draw a line between
there going all the way back as far
as possible and you can see we're over
600
000 deaths in 2020 the last time we had
more than 600 000 deaths was 1918
so the year of the spanish influenza uh
the year the final year of world war one
really gives you a sense of what we're
talking about here but probably you've
noticed there is an issue
with this data it's not population
adjusted and over this period
the population in england and wales and
indeed the uk has risen so
really we do need to adjust for
population and if we do it's a somewhat
different picture so same thing again
same kind of times same different
episodes of mortality and what i've done
instead is we've taken deaths per
thousand of the populations so we've got
a population adjustment here
and you can see a clear trend can't you
it's coming down people are living
longer you've got improvements medical
improvements
which mean that fewer people are dying
as
a percentage of the population until we
get to here so covert 19 let's just look
at what happened in 2020 again so 2020
data just through
shows that and it's not as big an
increase
as you saw in that other chart is it in
fact we're talking about 10 per
thousand the last time we're at that
kind of level was 2003 it doesn't sound
like all that long ago does it so it's
worth bearing that in mind
but here's the thing it's the change in
direction
that really matters here if you're
really making a good comparison here
to see how this year or indeed last year
compares
with the years around it you need to do
an excess death comparison so you're
taking
the particular year you're in at the
moment comparing it with the death level
you had in previous years and that's
what i've done here
this is population adjusted excess death
and just how much those deaths are
changing compared
with the previous five-year average
again the same thing we can compare
where we are now with previous
episodes where you had high levels of
mortality and here's what this data
shows you
so you can see for most of history it's
not going that far from
uh that zero line and the zero line
basically suggests things staying the
same as they were
in the previous year when you adjust for
population you had high levels
of mortality and then you had kind of
low levels of mortality
when you're going back uh to the kind of
victorian period there
but around this period for the most part
it was fewer deaths
until we got to 2020 i'm going to add on
the line for what happened in 2020 and
you can see a very big increase here
in excess debt we're looking at
historical excess deaths in england and
wales compared
with going all the way back to 1840 and
if we draw a line here
the last time excess deaths were as high
and this is population adjusted was high
as they were last year in 2020 the last
time we had a 12
increase in deaths or anything close to
it was 1940 so the middle uh
of world war ii you had that period uh
where you had very high levels of
civilian deaths
it's it's worse than any any of these uh
post-war pandemics worse than hong kong
flew
worse than 1951 flew worse than the
asian flu which was also
in the 1950s it is a very severe
increase in excess deaths but again this
isn't really
the gold standard of measuring these
things if you really want the gold
standard you need to look at what's
called
age standardized mortality which adjusts
it by population but also by
age levels throughout the population and
here's what you get
if you look at that now it's slightly
different this time anything above the
line is kind of good news that's
improving
mortality anything below the line is
deteriorating mortality
and again the same kind of picture these
are bars so for each year you're showing
whether you're getting better mortality
or worse
mortality and for the most part for most
of the 20th century
most of these bars are kind of above the
line people are living longer they're
doing better
but just look at what happens in 2020
you can see the bar goes
all the way down what we're looking at
here are annual changes
in mortality age-adjusted mortality
as produced by the institute and faculty
of actuaries and
again same exercise let's draw that line
back
into history and work out the last time
we had a 13
annual fall in mortality or anything
like it well
not since 1929 1929 there was a flu
epidemic
a pandemic and at the same time you had
obviously the wall street crash and uh
you had an economic toll as well so
we are talking about you know pretty
much however
you look at the numbers in most of these
comparable mortality calculations
this is the worst in many many years and
we're only you know a fraction of the
way through
this pandemic more people still dying at
the moment it's deeply depressing
if we just compare those periods so
again it's that same chart but what i've
done is just
picked out the years where you had the
biggest annual mortality falls
uh in england and wales well here is
where 2020
ranks i'll just kind of highlight it
there there's covert 19. so
these are the the biggest of all in
terms of years where mortality
deteriorated 1895 the great freeze very
high
uh levels of mortality that 1929 i just
mentioned a moment ago
flu and depression then there comes
covered 19 then you've got 1847 famous
cholera
uh outbreaks uh then 1950 uh 1915 and
then 1940s so during world war one
and during world war ii it's worth
saying just there are various different
ways of measuring this and due to the
fact that this is just annual changes
the spanish influenza doesn't really
show up here as much because it came in
you know after world war one when there
were high levels of mortality anywhere
there aren't you know there isn't one
single definitive way of measuring this
stuff
but pretty much whatever you look at
this is bad
you know it's very bad in compare
comparison with pretty much
any period you're looking at here and i
think that's the striking thing you know
this comes before you consider the
number of people who might whose lives
might have been
saved by all the lockdowns it comes
before you consider the fact that we
still have
more people potentially yet to die of
this disease it just goes to show this
really has been a historic pandemic